good afternoon everyone my name is Junsu
church council
welcome you to the 56th Edward HQ
Memorial Lecture this has been a
long-standing tradition of Danielle and
we are very much indebted to dr. Hughes
friends and family for supporting us
with this very important lecture series
and we have only once a year since 1960
beginning with John Fairmeadow actually
dr. Hume devoted much of his long
vigorous life to working in China and
elsewhere and the cause of health care
and medical training
he graduated from Yale College on our
own in 1897 and received his medical
degree four years later from Johns
Hopkins University he worked in India in
1983
1905 people are going to China well he
actually founded a scion medical school
and hospital under the auspices of
Yellin in China so this is also a very
long-standing tradition at Yale he
served as a president of the College of
yell in China from 1923 18 1927 I
returned to the US but was recalled to
China in 1934 it worked for several
years in liaison with the Chinese
National Health Administration shortly
after its death in 1957 funds were
colleagues friends and family enabled
the establishment of this lectureship to
bring to Yale eminent scholars of East
Asian Studies and we've done this every
year now for a few decades but I think
today we have a particular special
guests in fact professor Stephen Owen is
not a stranger to yell at all he started
here 1972 as an assistant professor in
1980 two decades before he was snatched
away by the institution of two hours
north and he actually also goes even if
history goes even further back than that
because professor I want to actually
receive both his
and PhD Yale 1968 1972 essentially he
would have stayed and could have stayed
but what we are most happy about is that
he has now returned to us I think today
is a it is a quite a remarkable occasion
because as I as I saw his I was reading
his abstract announced the title of his
talk
returning to the height song 35 years
later you just tweak the numbers that
can very well the Yale thirty-five years
later and the honor of this I was
actually looking at one of Professor
Owens first books in fact the first book
that grew out of his dissertation here
and it was a review by James mill in the
Harvard German Asiatic studies the most
striking thing is that back then you
could have bought this book for $15
which is not really possible anymore but
the observations that Professor Hugh
made of this young brilliant scholar who
is destined to be a teacher to almost
everyone in Chinese literary studies in
the u.s. and he said that mr. Owen
displays considerable sensitivity to
nuances of meaning verbal subtleties
poetic devices and stylistic traits and
he also remarked how his contribution in
his mind was able to make sense to give
appreciation understanding of the often
difficult and bizarre poetry of motuhake
now I would like to say that if
professor the award here today I was in
a little cookie you have expected that
these became the theory standards at
which he judged all his students and
having been one of them all the mores an
outlier than the proper student in cream
on
and these studies I am sure that his
famous three-hour pre general generals
still give students nightmares and
perhaps something to aspire to in the
future I actually won't like to say that
Professor
Owen has many dear friends and
colleagues in the audience in many ways
I came quite late at least on the yellow
side and I'll just like to say that I
think I speak for all of us that we are
so grateful in some ways and it's
actually warm a heartwarming occasion
for us to have you back here and to talk
about your return ok introductions are
always very hard to live up to awesome
he lost your talk yeah I wouldn't play I
was thinking in the council of East
Asian Studies for inviting me here
things talked about I will tell you a
secret about Jing it took me a long time
to persuade her not to try to write two
dissertations she was determined to do
both the modern dissertation and the
classical dissertation uh and I'm an old
yaly undergrad graduate student
professor and I was with a lot of human
lectures I haven't been to humor for
some time but I never imagined that I
would find myself on this side of the
human lecture looking out at you as some
of you know I wrote a book on the poetry
of the high Tong in back in 1980 that's
the 35 years when I was still at Yale
and I would a return to the topic to see
what looks different to me after 35
years
this is an interesting enterprise right
letting us think about how fields change
how we change and I want to warn the
younger scholars in the audience right
the danger of writing a book because it
has no expiration date people still cite
you what she wrote when you're in your
early 30s you can't take it back
I suppose that's as it should be and
fortunately I don't base achill II
disagree with what I wrote then but I
still see things rather differently down
and what I think has changed is the map
of the tradition of the tradition as it
now appears in place of a relatively
stable set of categories that can be
used at least provisionally the Chinese
tradition now seems like a vast fluid
field of evasions inventions forgetting
and selective memory which are shaped by
now forgotten motives opportunities and
accidents what seemed clear and certain
that now seems rather uncertain this is
not the way of course it's taught in
China and China is inscribed in stone so
replete with scholarly detail that
graduate students are routinely
directors a very small part of the
backwoods in order to write their names
but once you develop a that critical
twitch I think part of my Yale training
and starts asking questions the illusion
of stability often becomes merely the
trace of some later formation and we
soon begin to discover that the
scholarly field is not only not complete
but I think we're just barely beginning
to work on this and in that spirit I
want to turn to a cornerstone of the
receive tradition the so-called high Tom
anyone who studies China at all has
heard of the high Tong the shunt on when
you study poetry you know this is
supposed to be the high point be the
best the grand moment I don't know if
anybody here was in the Great forest age
with my luxury
if you but the odd thing is if you look
at the sole reception of tong poetry it
quickly becomes quite clear that the
readers the critics and the poet's
weren't interested in the high Tom pole
high time at all quite apart from Li Bai
and du feu course and for a lesser
degree with what a little of Wong way
among kohlrabi not very much uh some
poets and critics were not only
disinterested in the high tongue they
were largely equally disinterested in
pre tong except for tae-hyun being they
just didn't read it and then you start
looking well that's about that word Chun
Tong hi Tom when does that first appear
it appears all through the Song Dynasty
it's the name of a county it has nothing
to do with poetry until about 12:20 and
it appears where is my there was I hope
they goes the water now I did have a
mouse somewhere here and you can't use
PowerPoint without a mouse oh there it
is that's great okay okay it doesn't
appear until that song lungs poetry talk
satsang alone sir wah by nu we don't
know
then use dates or the data that son lung
sir wah it was probably written the 12
20s or 12 30s so half a millennium after
the shun time itself the crazy thing
about that song long sir hua was it was
immediately influential as soon as the
book came out it became the standard
especially the 12 40s on largely unread
poets began to be read again people
whose names were never mentioned all of
a sudden appear throughout remarks on
poetry these poems began to appear in
anthologies and even to dominate them
young you not only invented this
work this is his creation I not only
invented this worm he made it the very
center of a narrative Chinese poetry
let's survive in this day the Shu
audacity of this just shakes me up
suppose I wrote a book for claiming that
the early poetry of early that the rain
early reign of Henry the eighth was
really the high point of English poetry
you had to note that hardly anyone reads
that you have to really do it really
well to read Wyatt and Surrey the
Elizabethan era represents the beginning
of a sad decline in the quality of
English poetry which has gone steadily
downhill ever since they then not only
were to make this weird claim but within
five or ten years everybody would
believe it
all of the anthologies would change and
the unread poetry of Henry the eighth's
early reign would now dominate the study
of English poetry
you might try to say well maybe the
Romantic poets had some good room for
20th century people no I can't be as
good as that okay I'm just the thought
of getting away with that is amazing
you might suppose that young you meant
Levi and du feu and he had said hi Tom
no he doesn't mean that if you read gain
you carefully it's stranger than that at
this point one of these things move that
around there this one I just explained
what it says I won't translate
he says the student should first read
the height of famous height on poets
shun tongue means yeah and only then
really buy and do food it's a necessary
context for reading Levi and do food or
sometimes we do food Levi first then via
the high Tom poets and somehow they're
on this large unread sphere of
perfection that lies around the biome du
feu it's at the heart of the history of
Chinese poetry and the very condition by
which you have been really by and doufu
the high crown was not simply a new
period in Chinese poetry but a narrative
function in account of classical Poe
from the Honda the Sun present given not
simply his literary history but as a
curriculum he's the first person who
said read everything in chronological
order
if study of poetry sure [ __ ]
in contrast of the earlier critic
wanting Jen's use of the past is a kind
of open reservoir you pick things out
you change them around you use them in
the present you know certain student had
to learn the poetic past chronologically
and the largely unread poetry the pre
time period was part of that curriculum
so that also got the treetog the widget
number child back into the curriculum
then you firmly believed that everything
had gone downhill after the high talk
and in different passages he gives
different contradictory advice what a
student should do after you read up to
the high top well in one case it says
close your book don't read anything else
if you read anything after the high Tom
it will infect you and the worst kind of
poetry demon will enter your body then
he gets very angry and a little bit
later and he says go ahead read it read
all the way through but if you don't see
how bad poetry is after the high Tom
nobody could ever teach you anything
you're so stupid it's this cool old
Chinese schoolmaster and I might had
here that this literary historical
narrative Kurt narrative as a reading
curriculum was probably Enders changes
most enduring influence on the Chinese
literary landscape before yeah new
poetry anthologies were not often or
often not organized chronologically
after yeah new poetry anthologies are
always organized chronologically to this
day so what made the High Times so good
that's a good question
what's its most important characteristic
its characteristic is that it has no
characteristics
poetry's are seeing what is in the heart
in the stirring and excitement of their
poetry the height on writers were those
antelopes have hanged by their horns
leaving no tracks to be followed where
they are subtle there's a
limpid and sparkling quality can never
quite be fixed and determined like tones
in the empty air or color in a face or
moonlight in the water or on the image
in the mirror the words are exhausted
but the meaning is never exhausted this
actually has to be understood in
relation to notion of fire method and
there's nothing you can study here this
kind of perfection could only be grasped
by a kind of enlightenment using
Buddhist terms which you can reach only
if you follow the entire history of
Chinese poetry up to the high top now
you think that when you get there you're
going to have this Epiphany
you understand that you'll be able to do
it but no in yen use belated world of
epic gods once the student grasps the
possibility of such poetry he'd be able
to achieve only the middle level if you
only read that if you actually read the
middle stuff you're only gonna be the
worst and God knows what happens if you
read the really bad stuff I don't want
to think about that now yen use
supremely weird and melancholy poetic
pedagogy in effect replaced the entire
vision understanding of tong poetry as
it had been to that point you know the
song like the ninth century like the mid
time in the late Tom and Levi new food
it installed a new narrative which
though revises augmented remains in
place to this day you can't remove the
high Tong because it has a pivotal
function in the story of Chinese poetry
its success was astoundingly quick as I
said there is a big anthology appeared
in 1240 for sure and you chef
starts off with the basic statement on
what poetry is
it starts off quoting the Nu that's
about ten years later now if we
understand Yin use intervention and
support intervention here sounds very
good and the role of high Tom and his
literal historical narrative it frees us
to return to the era and look at it it's
a fresh way I think rather than an era
in its own right it may have been simply
a transition
illusi for that reason and it would go
for that reason it is neither here nor
there between eras that do have traces
and are imitable on the one side earlier
they have court poetry which has strict
rules of exposition diction conventions
closely tied to topics that you can
imitate that all over the place on the
other side you have a highly
self-conscious poetry the Midtown and
late Tom which was so understood all too
well but in the middle rather than an
elusive pure poetry that happened in
history but didn't really belong to it
that's what Yin Yue was basically saying
you may find a poetry that is in deep
deeply grounded in its moment and
succeeds precisely because there's
validity at the moment now yeah new
really isn't talking about the
heightened poets he's actually talking
about a small group of them he doesn't
mean the coordinate courtiers were still
very important he doesn't mean the
Arceus or becoming very important he
means the poet's end of an anthology
called huh giggling G from 754 at least
these are the poets have come to define
the high table including Levi but of
course not du feu cuz he hadn't written
much by 754 most were ginger graduates
would Levi in Hmong Haram being
exceptions almost none came from
distinguished families Wang Wei being
the exception they all have her belong
to a network of polling exchange it's
useful to compare this anthology with
another contemporary anthology called
[ __ ] show gee I didn't put that in
your notes which was a product of the
Imperial Academy that Goya's Gorge out
of wall and you know don't quite know
how to translate dynasty capital you
know heartland if we choose what we can
call it a collection of the flower of
the capital
however we translated the title is
oriented toward the imperial center and
you open the book you look at the table
of contents every poll is given with his
office those who had no office become
true sure reckless or Jin shirt which
means you came to take the examination
you didn't pass an impressive number of
these people had central government
offices as it's at all it's a anthology
representing the capital in contrast
Hellyeah Yingling ji can be roughly
translated as collection of the geniuses
of the rivers and great mountains the
term hai-yah is a variant on shan huh
you know you all know you do football
for Shan hoods on side
well that means dynastic territory
iswhat's not but what the ball has not
what the ball is you can say gorgeous
Shanghai but you can't say Chandra war
even though Wang Wei served in the
central government the title of the
anthology position geniuses outside the
capital the anthology Infante was
himself from zhang zhehan danyoung right
near modern Zhang Jian and he compiled
an anthology of don young poets he's
talking about the poetry of the Empire
not of the capital all the poets of the
gorgeo ji were by and large not great
couriers the two anthologies are
weighted very differently which brings
us to the question was being a ginger
very important the Tong dynasty the
people who passed the juncture
examination said yes the people who
really held power in the Tom said yes if
the person comes from a good family but
they seem to devote their lives to
making sure that nobody who is none of a
good family who passed the ginger
examination rose of the level of County
Sheriff
they never hardly ever rose higher than
the bottom of the official ladder this
is the young man from Yale who once we
work on Wall Street and make a bundle it
ends up running a Bank of America branch
the small town in Arkansas
that's what passing the ginger Jesse we
know the tonk scholars know quite well
ginger graduates made up only a
diminutive proportion of the Empire's
office holders and those who had real
power as I said made sure they didn't
rise any higher than the bottom real
power in the town was always held by a
very small group of families who
intermarried and supported one another
and this Nick tackle that's just very
nicely demonstrated they belong to the
Capitals they moved the family tombs to
the Capitals they are the servants of
empire if their children took the
examination remember the one thing with
the tongue examination separates it from
later on the tongue you wrote your name
on the examination oh that's so and so
sung and they took most of the ginger
passes yep they always let a few people
get in from the outside not many so
perhaps the best way to understand the
place of the ginger in the tongue elite
is go back before the high tongue to the
period when the ginger ranks opened up
under empress wu who was then ruling but
not reigning in jungle was a ginger
graduate of 766 75 rather renowned for
his talent he's the protagonist and
probable author of a book of a story of
the novella called yo shanku the grotto
of wandering immortals or whatever and
this is the ultimate ginger fantasy you
take the old erotic story of the young
man or man wandering in the mountains
meeting two goddesses and sleeping with
them and then leaving and you transpose
her to tongue geography tonk history
tongue social situations and you have
this story on his way to take up an
entry-level post of County Sheriff they
all had to be County sheriff's John
encounters two beautiful widows in an
opulent villa in the mountains the
widows identified themselves as she
hunts white that is that swea clan of
the ching hog branch one of the most
prestigious of all families in the
tongue unfortunately about these great
families as they had kids all over the
place and after a few generations there
are more trinkets ways you could count
so being a Ching not swayed itself
doesn't help you what you've got to do
is you have to say who did you marry
so she proudly then make sure that you
know that she each of the widows married
had married somebody of an equally
distinguished clan who held very high
officers and been convened ly killed in
battle so that's the way of saying these
are not these are not in God's ways Wow
right this establishes them as who's who
of the Tong now what's interesting is
the opening thing with madam sway meets
the young ginger graduate Zhang's war
and treats him with utter disdain in
response we hear the first for the first
time the most familiar refrain of all
ginger from not from very good families
my family was very prominent in the Han
Dynasty we held you know ministerial
posts for generation after generation we
fell on hard times for about five six
centuries now we're back me but I think
every Jeong said that everybody has
famous ancestors Madame's way when she
hears this is not impressed and the
story itself is basically a long
demonstration of Gyeongju is verbal
cultural and toxify light bill archery
skills family to win the ladies lust and
be invited to her bed
this is of course the second successful
examination the young Jung's will has
been through more rewarding the first
it's hard that to see this story as an
allegory of the new class of examination
graduates imagining that they will be
accepted by the ironclad ranks of the
realtime elite and of course the answers
together now in a later age by the time
we get to 750 for these people as I said
never wrote a rose above the level of
County Sheriff it was a very bottom of
the ladder but 75 years after Johns Road
they no longer had any fantasies that
they ever would be accepted by the
ruling class and get into it
and there's a new tone and this made
part of understanding the poetry of the
era this is part of the agenda of hiring
Ling Qi scene in the very first entry on
the first poet represented Chongjin and
it says they say that there are never
noblemen among the greatest talents and
this is indeed true and everybody who
died in low posts who had talent
including transient who passed away as
what as a County Sheriff
Indian fans eyes this even this is a
community that by virtue of its talents
was destined never to hold power and the
common kind of social prestige although
many ginger graduates were not
particularly good at poetry and although
they were scattered in many places
I think they constituted themselves as a
community outside the ruling elite
buying logs through poetry which was for
them the instantiation of their talent
they often proclaimed a disinterest in
prestige and power knowing that they
really wanted it and the phrase aiming
to get one name is often used for the
examination the Empire emperor has the
power to make you a graduate right
that's your first fame with this
community claim the power to grant me
apart from the imperial
they said we can make you famous and
this meaning of course unlike the other
separate spheres in the tongue was a
family name Chong is a sir Gregor
surname you can rise the top of the
Sangha and Buddhism you have to have a
mungus name if you have become a very
prominent Dallas do you have a Dallas
style someone something so yeah there
had been regional groups apart from the
imperial center at earlier history I
think of the eastern gym but I think
this is probably the best candidates
you're going to find for the beginnings
of an empire-wide literati at least tiny
but at least partial independence of the
state the Empire can give me an office
but it can't make me a good poet I can
tell you your fear good poets has been
fun at the heart of this at Independence
is claiming the power of authoritative
judgment regarding Fame and
simultaneously denying that authority to
the center the emperor can grant office
and political power but he can't
successfully declare somebody as a great
poet in infants preface we see an
interesting inversion social political
reality if those with power saw the
talented poets without family
backgrounds of air lopers in a stable
political system the Infante imagines
those without talent but possessing
status what used their authority to get
into the fan ecology so he says from the
doctor home rain down to the tub ten
Bahrain nearly a thousand held the brush
in hand exclude the pair of the
politically powerful those who gave
bribes for inclusion and anthology he
imagined people are going to bribe you
to get into his anthology scarcely 40
percent of eminent inestimable you can't
even follow joy as them all so and and
if a person's reputation does not match
the actual situation if their town is
not in accord with a way that even if
their power over top said of a young ji
and Doshi an Eastern Han Grandy's I
would never include them
so Ian Phan puts himself in the role of
the community's gatekeeper keeping out
the untalented and powerful member of
the Tong oligarchy and who I think in
the infants imagination might seek
inclusion reputation here is not
conferred by the state but rather by a
consensus of the community that Yin Phan
claims to represent any intrusion of
state sanctioned power and that judgment
must be resisted the great families were
an urban oligarchy and their poetic
production was largely in the regions of
the two capitals if their rusticated
they look back towards the Capitals
longingly our other community of
talented poets excluded from power
circulated in the Empire outside the
capitals and the Empire's mountains and
rivers in this community we begin to see
poetry used in lateral communication do
you don't mean by that your has seen
poems being sent a crop not to the
capital and back from the capital being
set across the Empire to other places
other provincial places they visited
local officials and no doubt and
gratitude for hospitality hospitality
rather celebrated them it became a
network of mutual recognition completely
suffered from the power of the center to
assign status and prestige from local
officials to temples the county count
Country Gentlemen politely called Rec
loses reputation circulated in poems
it's not that we don't see this earlier
the volume of extant production and the
geographical extent was unprecedented
if Chung on Luang ruled the Empire this
period created and culturally mapped the
Empire in a larger sense for the urban
oligarchy the Empire outside the
Capitals was a tax base basically a
source of luxury goods but a most
unwelcome place to live
nobody wanted to live outside shot on
her law yeah unless you have to be set
as prefect of where the really rich
cities which can milk for all the money
it's worth and come back our community
of poets celebrated a larger Empire and
made it a map of places with aura
this is a real poetic investment in
place our high tongue poets may have
spent the career is moving from one
provincial place to the other but the
collective consequence of that was the
beginning of a tourist map of the Empire
and just the one a poem everybody was
reading poetry knows yellow crane tower
now in Wuhan southern long ago already
rode the white clouds away in all the
remains in this place is yellow crane
tower once the yellow crane went away it
never returned again for a thousand
years on white clouds just go on and on
on the sunlit River are clearly seen the
trees of Han young and spring plants
grow in profusion Ampera dial at sundown
where is it the pass that leads towards
home misty wave of the room being a
person sad oh well some earlier voyager
going past yellow yellow crane tower the
boatman may have said here's the legend
that's the place no one would ever have
known about him but once this sway hop
hold we put into circulation it was very
popular people would and you know people
would go there in order to see what sway
how saw guys and their response becomes
oh that's yellow crane tower right
architecture is not very durable in
China
I decided Chinese architecture ephemeris
like Lincoln Logs
you know you can build wonderful things
with it take the pieces apart and put
them up somewhere else and falls down
there's always going to be a yellow
crane tower now in Wuhan it's been
burned down and rebuilt so many times
but the poem needs a building does if
you don't have the bill that you can't
say so that's yellow crane tower right
you've read about as a kid now you have
place there's also shang yang
in modern who bay it had its own songs
largely forgotten until li by the
voracious reader remembered them
it had many sites and stories and
geographical lore in the 7th century
chunzhen had visited and used allusions
that we never see again nobody read his
poem once manga Ron and Levi got there
everybody knows what chou-heung
is it's the door laid a the steely for
shedding tears its jeong-ja foooor the
glimpse of the Han River it's you know
upon the gold and the recluse who flees
with his family when he's gotten was
serving it's you know the drunk of the
drunken Gemma the drunken governor
xiangjian with his jelly hat on upside
down coming back drunk with all the kids
laughing at even clapping their hands
Shang young became a place
everybody knows his poetry it was
transformed by poetry if you check out
the contemporary Xiang yang website
you'll find all of this there you won't
find the illusions that Chen Zhong used
you'll find the illusions used in the
height on poles we see the sure
durability of their publicity and we see
that we begin to understand why party
travelers were so welcomed to
entertained in their peregrinations if
you live to see you live in a small city
with a long history or some
out-of-the-way temple and a spectacular
landscape the point is your advertising
agency it makes you feel like this is
really a nice place he's a cheap hire
give a little food little drink place to
sleep for a while maybe a little money
and from a backwater you've suddenly
become a famous place in the Empire
that's a good bargain and travelers will
come there just to see the place that
was celebrated by Levi's Palmer among
herons pull the temples would often set
the poems up in the courtyard until the
ninth century when too many pointy
travelers were coming by and that the
temples were littered with um poems they
put them over wooden boards and they
took them down afterwards but still if
you go to a lot of temples it's been
celebrated you'll find in carbon metal
or stone you'll find one of those tong
poems
right Jen Cong Jin Ling Nanjing had been
burned to the ground in the sway
conquest' I suspect that the sway orders
were pretty much confined to the centre
of the city to not the places around it
there are a few earlier why Google
amends for the past about the place but
really Li Bai invented Nanjing you know
he was the one that we celebrated all
his spots gave it all sorts of famous
poems after that a lot of other people
did because really he helped create that
city as a what it is now and it's not
just Xiang yang know you know Han dong
with his beauties and carousing G bei
was gallant knight erence
the rich somewhat anachronistic lore of
the frontier as a cultural space judge
from contemporary writings China of 750
looked very very different than China of
700 because by 750 it's not just John
William by 750 there's a whole world of
China as a space the high time didn't
complete the map doufu added chengdu
with some predecessors do MU at at
yeongjo but by the end of the Tong
there's a cultural poetic map of the
rest of China that made the Empire no
longer just a Rome an immensely
successful city-state but rather it had
become in imperial territory made it for
many places it was more than a map it
was a community the post praised one
another and all those who entertain them
they celebrated a way of life beyond the
Emperor's reach we can be sure that
almost all of them wanted office but
failing that they could conjure up into
their poetry a way of life that was
preferable they to talk themselves into
it they had a way of life that was
preferable whose attractions were
discursive Li realized
okay I'm gonna skip up section here now
I'd like to argue that as this community
forming around the composition of poet
its circulation of poetry took shape
they were thinking about Empire and its
limits the easiest obvious example is
their development of the older poetry of
the recluse into the celebration of
private life and Diouf we left extensive
documentation a life of seeking patron
what that was like which is the only way
you could get ahead for those didn't
belong to the oligarchy itself he
praises he flatters he thanks attends
the morning levies of Brandis punctually
with thoughts of giving up and going off
like among haram but there is a more
profound critique of the Empire taking
shape the best way to put it is to ask
the grand question does an empire
emperor have the Empire or does the
Empire have an emperor the question
gestures are the dude dominant models of
imperial rule right there's an
ideological correct model the Emperor
Labor's for the good of his people takes
responsibility for their well being
that's the Empire has an emperor right
and tied them does this theatrically in
the performance of this role that's what
ability liked him so much the jung
hwan's yung yau another point of view
the Empire is the personal possession of
the emperor he possesses the Empire in
representations in the Capital Region by
a constant stream of information that's
what the imperial court system is for
tribute of luxury goods representing the
diversity and wealth of his territory
the Emperor then distributes much of
those guns to the oligarchy where they
to show them their stake in having you
know in the Empire and then isn't just
the necessity of the Emperor's mediation
and keeping their own position and you
know this is a long history ginger Wong
building miniature capitals of all the
states he conquered around the capital
Johan wood
bringing in the religious practitioners
from all over the Empire to perform all
the religious ceremonies in the capital
and even even uh with tides of building
a lota sponsor could have John not
noticing will grow very well in Shannon
but he had to have his girls go out
harab ladies go out and you know paddle
around to gloat asses to have the Empire
now as unified excluded nur ability from
the ranks of great talents and had
excluded the powerful from in the ranks
of his anthology we get to see a high
ten an interest in what the Emperor and
by extension the great families cannot
have talent and recognition from having
talent was the infants answer you can't
make somebody great poet I can do that
but I want to pick up a peculiar case as
minor as it might seem the most simple
thing the Emperor cannot own
theoretically owns but can't have rather
a very British a famous story whose
think actual significance has gone
unrecognized the great tongue Emperor
dot on tenza living in Chiang on can't
have lychees a delicious fruit widely
available where it grows but which
begins to lose its savor the moment is
picked when John killing the one of the
rare people who became minister who was
not from a great family wrote his fool
in the lychee sometime between 727 and
731 an administrative exile the poetry
creation of the Empire was already well
underway
John was a sent from Guangdong praised
the flavor of his local fruit and made a
prophetic suggestion he says unless rush
to Chong gone by the courier system
it cannot be enjoy this is delicious
challenge literally delicious challenge
pitting a local fruit against imperial
power and its institutional
instantiation the courrier system which
will win and of course the challenges
taken up in the famous story of young
boy Fay and her lychees Gong Wu Fei was
from Phu Joe liked fresh lychees and the
Emperor has them brought by speedy
courier courier crushing down the
farmers an ostentatious example that the
Emperor Emperor says I have the Empire
rather than vice versa we'll never know
how the lychees transported by courier
to China and compared to Li Jie's
freshly-picked doufu claims you've
tasted Li Chang on lychees and those
fresh off the trees reflected on this
issue which I in a poem sequence one of
my favorite one of the bless read of
them sequence called Qi among which I
translate as getting rid of the blues no
where's my thing here ah it's all about
food and poetry that which circulates in
the Empire and that which can't
circulate in the Empire except in
representation the sequence was written
early in the Dali
reign which gave you thought as a
beginning of the fall from perfection of
a high time but do full of course is
exempted but I think I can understand
why they would say that from the very
first quorum we know we're in do food
world Maori it for you the translation
at least thoughts pavilion ramshackle
gates dwellings scattered like stars
waves rolled river blackens the rain
begins to fall a mountain verb brings
its chicks to feed read feed them red
berries the girl by the creek gets a
coin and leaves a white fish huh
everything is local right the place the
weather at the moment but they're in the
middle of the poem the last line is this
tie and tumble and tug bow says it all
the same thing of value that circulates
toll it can be used for an exchange
anywhere including backwater cuejoe
where do food was living but the fish is
friendly
however delicious it's not going
anywhere
90 was the Emperor himself no matter how
much you can pays he could afford to buy
it you can't have it unless he comes to
cuejoe and notice the Duke who doesn't
say buy and sell here he just reports
what he sees he sees that coin picked up
they should put down something
equivalence going on here can you think
I'm overeating uh I know my do fool when
I first read this I didn't know exactly
where what's [ __ ] who's gone next
poem ago next poem would go but I had
some sense I know the issues that were
at stake number two a foreign makes us
leave going downriver the young Joe I
recall when climbing up stairs and the
old post Lodge a shilling and why not
find out for me where the rice is dear
or cheap following my friend this old
fellow wants to go roaming east so
here we see circulation right people who
travel don't just sit around cuejoe not
just any merchant a foreign merchant not
the visually innocent exchange mating
cuejoe
: fish not even called exchange but
commodity prices if you're going down to
Gyan to yong-jo find out how to the
Rice's and send them work message to me
and maybe I'll come join you do food
speculating a movie himself told
circulating if the price is right
coins and portable carbohydrates are the
stuff of Empire and I begin to have a
theory that the Empire may be nothing
more profound a system of circulating
excess carbohydrates that's all it is
but in the first two poems he sets his
terms focus on the local and immediate
versus long-range planning based on
information mobility always engaged with
food right ones right here it doesn't
use the word buying the other one talks
about going around the Empire and turns
the carbohydrates now this is a great
sequence I don't have time to do the
whole thing unless your stay here all
night do for shifts to the heightened
poets whose works circulate everywhere
like Imperial coins and grain but the
poems difference because in circulate
they remember the local and local foods
always there the representation of the
local had been the prerogative of the
imperial center here it circulates
through the empire I also recall Xiang
Yang's mahara line after line of elusive
poems all worth handing on circulating
these days among the gaffer's fresh
phrases fresh phrases are no more they
merely fished by a log for the neck
contracting brand the course were back
to fishing again we start out with
fishing come to fishing again Fisher all
the way through except for leech trends
elite season and this refers to a line
by Maharana bout fishing for this
particular
kind of brown which they do in Xianyang
that circulates but nowadays the people
in Xianyang don't have the poem to
circulate but they thought of because
among hans pull them fish for dinner of
the first poem returns here as i said
they still fish in xiang yong but their
pullets gone the one whose lines make
the local fish famous coins and
carbohydrates be linked the empire
together
but the poet's make the particular and
the local part of the whole the air the
glue that ties it together they may
create Empire in a different sense the
ampere can no of them have intelligence
pump them but you can never eat them
these are all the things I'd like to eat
but I can't eat the emperor could
personally possess only representations
the sequence includes of course with a
bunch of poems on lychees the fruit that
can be fully appreciated only locally
and immediately you have to eat it right
off the tree the last poem returns to
Shandong as abuse who follow a folly
abusing the courtiers courrier system
causing local harm to have with the
Empire as favor can never have fresh
lychees do who had passed through one of
the two preeminent lychee regions on his
bond during 'z he had tasted the fruit
fresh off the tree and the temple in the
sequence there twelve poems the tenth
poem in the sequence says it all
I recall passing Ludo in Rome Joe I'm
picking lychees half hidden among the
green maples winding off the rocks the
ones I used to see in the Kapler we're
lacking all beautiful color the red
berries sweetness could be known by
myself alone only I could taste how good
they were
only the person who's been there and
know if what understands young you doof
who's already fallen from tall height on
perfection he was making a conceptual
claim rather than giving experience for
what he presents but like EW he's
thinking about the past and earlier
about hi tongs says he gives bodies to
infants contemptuous rejection of the
urban oligarchy in the capital's this
you can't have talent and lychees poetry
gave the emperor representations of the
beauties of his empire all he possessed
only in representation discursively he
could never go there oh god they're only
in representation and there's a fine
little story I didn't put this on
PowerPoint in no sunroofs ninth century
story collection she's young guy Lou
called min Wanda schenzel the emperor in
the cayenne rain visiting Guang Ling
Guang Ling is young Joe it goes like
this the story queue stood on the 18th
year of the cayenne rain that isn't 7:30
on the 15th mm the Lantern Festival the
Emperor addressed Dallas master yeah
saying the splendors of all the four
quarters of my Empire displayed on this
evening do you know which place has the
ultimate Beauty master yes said in
responsible for the sumptuous beauty of
lanterns and candles for display of
every kind of entertainment that the
charm of gentlemen and women infused
with powder and mascara there's no place
in the Empire the best young job the
Emer said what take technique new for me
to go to view this the master replied
why just your majesty
all your entourage may do so and the
Emperor and his entourage did Dean
wizard conjures up a bridge through the
clouds and the entire court goes walking
over the bridge and it's the young Joe
in about three minutes you know the law
very better best
citizens Chinese trains and they stand
up and they look down on young Joe and
wondering um and the people in young Joe
look up and see the Emperor and Messi
has suggested the emperor play skirts of
rainbow feather robes it's a famous
music of the Immortals of the court
played which the Emperor commands then
the Emperor's probably go back it's a
very fine moment only by magic can the
Emperor view the beauties of his empire
which in turn marvels at him but you
notice the uncrossable distance remains
he couldn't want to go and watch them
they can only look up and see him he
could never be there he is it close
enough to see he wonders it was just a
delusion and his information network his
quarter system next week brings him news
the people in yong-jo on the land eyed
the lantern festival saw the gods and
immortals appearing to them in the sky
so he knows he really was there but it
could only observe the other genius hai
Tong was a purely poetic perfection that
occurred on China in Chinese history but
transcended it once we escaped that era
of the high Tong we see a moving moment
there was very much part of history a
new empire of representations they
included the local a world that belonged
to a new community it was shared with
each locale to which they pass there are
indeed traces in the poetry perhaps mean
you didn't quite quite get it right
which is good I think but somewhat
impaired proof intuition their traces
inscribed there naked their negativity
there's the representations of what you
really can't have what's out of reach by
belonging to a moment to a place and a
person unless you can learn the pleasure
of these negative traces to accept the
representations rather than to have what
is represented you're going to always be
eating badly
cheese thank you